[Musik]
hallo hessen 4000 ist alice es heute
gibt es wieder eine richtig tolle motive
meine schweiz bei uns unten im garten
und dann habe ich meine nachfolge
gesehen und war hochschwanger und ich
hab gedacht mensch penny irgendwie
verletzte die küche anfangen denn ich
wusste gar nicht dass sie schwanger ist
jedenfalls hatte schon demnächst
entbindungstermin und kurze zeit später
habe ich ihre schwester gesehen und sie
wollte ihrer schwester eine baby orte
backen für ihre baby shower party 98
colitis übernimmst du und ich habe auf
diese zeit also mache ich ja diese worte
daher habe ich jetzt hier eine baby
shower torte gemacht für die liebe oxana
und in adwords die bekommen nämlich
demnächst ein kleines mädchen und daraus
entstanden ist die betreute klapsing
bisschen verspielt gemacht hier oben
drauf sitzt ein storch mit einem kleinen
beben mit einem roten tuch und die
steinfigur habe ich bereits in einem
separaten video gemacht da könnt ihr auf
jeden fall mal vorbeischauen
hier habe ich oben eine torte mit süßen
heißluftballons und da steckt eine
schokotorte mit kirsch wucht einlage und
einer herren schokoladen gemacht hier
unten habe ich eine verspielte torte mit
vielen kleinen fotos und darunter steckt
eine man durfte thronen torte mit
waldfrucht einlage und einer zitrone
vanille buttercreme ich habe das ganze
an zwei oder beziehungsweise zweieinhalb
tagen gemacht am ersten tag habe ich die
böden vorgebrachten und die waldfrucht
einlage gemacht und auch die
kirschfruchtfliege am zweiten tag habe
ich dann das ganze etwas performt
gefüllt und die deko natürlich auch
vorbereitet und heute habe ich die torte
fertig gestellt das heißt nämlich
einfach ein bisschen zeit und plant das
ganze gut und dann kann es wirklich gut
aufteilen
ich zeige euch jetzt wie ich angefangen
habe und
[Musik]
los geht's mit der unteren fordere dass
es eine mandel zitronen forte mit einer
vanille buttercreme und einer waldfrucht
einlage ich habe die böden bereits
vorgebacken und waren jetzt hier einen
25 zentimeter boden gebacken
das ist der lockere kuchen boden habe
die wahlspruch einlage und die vanille
buttercreme und alle rezepte findet ihr
bereits in den classic
die nehme ich jetzt eine 25 zentimeter
platz ist das ein clipboard und
bestreikt worden ist für mich extrem und
am besten ist es immer wenn ihr die
torten würden einen tag vorher macht das
heißt sie können dann im kühlschrank
wohnen abgedeckt und die frucht einlagen
die können wir auch schon vorbereiten
ihr kommt jetzt der erste boden drauf
und den habe ich in vier teile
geschnitten werden jetzt mit aber nehme
buttercreme und den frucht einlagen
gefilmt
[Musik]
die torte bietet zu eine stunde gekürzt
dafür lege ich jetzt auch noch den
torten dritte obendrauf so wird es schön
flach und danach kann ich sie dann
anschließend mit der restlichen butter
film komplett glatt streichen
und jetzt zeige ich euch nur für mich
die kleine torte fülle die obere pforte
hat einen durchmesser von 20 zentimetern
ich hab ich den boden auch bereits einen
tag vorher vorgebacken das ist ein muss
boden mit etwas schokostückchen dabei
einen spruch ein schlagerstar peter
gemacht und ich hab hier noch ein
bisschen schneller erwärmt das heißt sie
dort natürlich genauso und ich denke das
kommt jetzt auf meine tortenplatte dann
der erste boden drauf und die böden habe
ich jetzt auch in zwei torten gebacken
das heißt auch zweimal
so habe ich einfach zwei gramm torbögen
wo die torte wird schön hoch die werden
dann mit etwas von dem gelee bestrichen
und dann wie gerade eben auch bei der
großen torte gefüllt
[Musik]
die fahrt im netz ganz gestrichen und
die ständig jetzt für zwei stunden in
den kühlschrank taxi anschließend gut
ein in frischhaltefolie zum beispiel und
stellte damen über nacht in den
kühlschrank und am nächsten tag werden
sie dann mit von dort überzogen
die torten staat jetzt über nach dem
kühlschrank und jetzt werde ich damit
vollends überzeugen sie kennt das 15 km
bereits geknetet mache ich immer gerne
mit jetzt aus kokosfett und rollt den
von unseren auf beckers stärker und
[Musik]
dann nämlich jetzt die untere die große
torte und damit davon ganz gut haftet
nämlich etwas wachstumsfeld für studie
torte damit und legt an den von damm
trüber
[Musik]
die kleine torte übersicht mit
hellblauen von dann im darf jetzt
einfach einen sein weiß blau gemisch und
solange geknetet sich eine schöne farbe
hatte
das soll ich jetzt auch aus und über die
torte und zeigt euch gleich eine richtig
tolle zeit nicht immer schöne scharfe
kanten an vonlanthen hingekommen
[Musik]
die oberfläche und die seiten habe ich
jetzt ein geschenk geglättet jetzt zeige
ich euch wie ihr diese könnten hier
richtig schön eckig bekommt entweder
nehmen sie dafür eine decken vor das
einfach so und dann geht es auch oder
ihr könnt ihr dort auch oben drehen das
heißt hier sonsbecker stärke dann einen
trocken retter oben und unten und oben
drehen und das geht am besten mit torten
die mit einer klammer spielstunden sind
weil die gans stadtfest ist bei einer
buttercreme könnte jetzt auch machen
aber mit sehr vorsichtig sein
[Musik]
die hier unten
diese kleinen lücken und die werden sie
zu machen das heißt sobald ich jetzt den
vom landtag gegen flügge wird erfordert
natürlich oben schöneck ich mache jetzt
am besten mit einem trockenen blätter
einfach ganz vorsichtig sein
ein bisschen nach unten arbeiten
[Musik]
die taten haben jetzt den kühlschrank
und jetzt wenn die dekoration
vorbereiten und zwar kommen jetzt kleine
hals luftballons auf die torte
dafür habe ich mir hier eine schablone
aufgedruckt ihr könnt ihr auch selbst
zeichnen und in zwei teile geschnitten
das heißt zuerst einmal ist der ballon
an der reihe und ich habe jetzt vier
verschiedene farben bereits vorbereitet
und habe ich es einfach von hand
genommen
in grün gelb blau und habe rover modelle
schokolade und schoko von hand genommen
und alles mit blüten fast 1 für ein tram
ist außerdem oder schokolade
da braucht man es nämlich nicht nämlich
erst vermeintliches genau und für den
heißluftballon da ich den jetzt mit
vielen farben machen möchte brauche ich
einmal eine grundfarbe
das heißt freilich ist raus
hab ich die modelliermasse auf das leid
unserer lage gelegt und bestreitet die
masse wird er mit kokosfett und legitim
schablone drauf so schlemmer drumherum
[Musik]
in kleinen korb machen sie auf schoko
von land und den habe ich jetzt bereits
ausgerollt noch nicht zu sehen denn da
gehe ich mit mit der struktur rolle
eines besucher bekommen ist aktuell eine
schöne corp opti kennt machen und es
wird auch einfach ausgeschnitten
[Musik]
die
ich habe ich hier alles vorbereitet und
jetzt nämlich die restlichen farben
rolli aus schmeiße aus und mache hier
noch ein paar schöne muster mit drauf
und die kleine musterteile werden dann
mit kleber angeklebt es waren natürlich
[Musik]
lügen
die heißluftballons sind jetzt erstmal
seit ich will ständig zur seite ich
hab's noch mal alle fahren ganz dünn
ausgerollt
da werde ich kleine dreiecke machen und
eine sim karte drauf machen bis zu
kleinen film sind und hier mit noch
etwas weißem wir von dann ausgerollt zu
verkohlen der konsistenz den kann man
ganz dünn ausrollen ohne dass erreicht
erstmal anfangs ein bisschen schwieriger
film treten weil einfach kokosfett mit
drin steckt aber ansonsten ist die
verarbeitung super den habe ich jetzt
ein bisschen dicker gelassen
werdet ihr mittleren blumen aus löcher
mit blume ausstechen und dann einfach
nur mal aufräumen und sowie eine wolke
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die einzelnen
dekorationen auf torte kleben das mache
ich natürlich wieder mit esswaren kleber
und nehmen dort einen pinsel und zuerst
werde ich jetzt die heißluftballons
ankleben und die wilms kette sie kommt
dann so ein bisschen das zwischen und
die heilung verlaufe gebe es also
erstmal die oberseite und die feinen
linien also dieses eine mal ich dann mit
einem lebensmittel farbstift
[Musik]
das sei für die wimpelketten formatiert
mit meiner freundin und die presse herr
14 weisen von land weiß geknetet die
vorne ist eine ganz kleine feine loch zu
loch
jetzt kann ich das ganze herauspressen
nein
[Musik]
die untere pforte an der reihe hier die
sitzung bitte auch vorbereitet und zwar
ganz viele bunte kreise ausgestochen
und das habe ich mit einer spritztour
gemacht mit 2,5 cm und durch mit seinen
etwa und hab ich jetzt ganz viele
verschiedene tolle farben genommen habe
ich jetzt die torte und etwas backpapier
trophäe geht auch sehr gut ich habe
alles grad kennt also nämlich backofen
und habe auch zufällig die perfekte
breite und wenn nicht schneidet ihr sehr
einfach gerecht denn jetzt machen wir
die wachs papier transfer methode in
meinem fall die bank auf ihr land
vermittelt das backpapier und gezeiten
von dem kokosöl drauf so können die
kreise schön angeben und das ziel ist es
jetzt die kreise hier auf dem backpapier
drauf zu legen und dann mit hilfe von
button 4 an die torte zu kleben
ihr könnt natürlich auch jeden einzelnen
kreis hier an die torte kleben aber dann
steht die torte zum ersten ein bisschen
zu lange im warmen also bei
zimmertemperatur und außerdem drückte
dann vielleicht mit den schräg an und
liefern und tue ich es einfach ein
ordentlicher jetzt kann ich die kreise
nehmen und die wirklich sehr nach
belieben draufkleben falls es nicht noch
ein bisschen vom platz
[Musik]
und dann einfach leicht andrücken und
jetzt das muster eurer wahl draufsetzen
bei mir sind liegt kreise jetzt
größtenteils rosa weil es einfach eine
mädchen plate orte werden soll und macht
pro reihe immer eine andere farbe mit
rein
jetzt werden die kreise ganz leicht mit
kleber bestrichen weiß nicht zu viel
nehmen und den papierstreifen habe ich
jetzt ein bisschen zugeschnitten so kann
ich ihn besser halten und nun habe ich
es ein und teils freigelassen und später
nach bedarf einfach noch halbe kreise
hinsetzen als vorsichtig hoch nehmen
dann die obere kante an die torte setzen
[Musik]
ganz groß am tiefpunkt jetzt ganz vorn
antreten und dann ist es hier auch
vorbildlich rechts sehen
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich den papierstreifen
dickere wurde gesamte torten
[Musik]
jede torte hat in rückseite vor allem
berufe hat und deswegen ist klar dass
irgendwo mit ihm kreise überlappten du
suchst bei mir hier das gegenteil
schneiden sie einfach weg und ich ganz
oben
das später nicht
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torten staffeln zum
stapeln haben hier eine dicke skateboard
und da habe ich bereits mit von und
überzogen und mit einer struktur rolle
darüber gerollt
das ganze ein bisschen antrocknen lassen
und jetzt kommt da der erste boden drauf
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die zweite karte oben
drauf setzen aber weil die torten
natürlich sehr schwer ist und beim
auflegen einpacken würde in die unsere
torte muss ich die torte stabilisieren
dazu könnt ihr zum beispiel cake pops
fix nehmen oder auch erreichen oder es
gibt auch diese dicken kunststoffrohre
die könnt ihr auch nehmen und es gibt
einfach nur zu schneiden service
dickerer ich habe jetzt leider nur eins
kommt bei mir in die mitte und da werde
ich mich abschneiden zwischen
lebensmittel steckt und dann nämlich zu
stabilisieren noch diese postings sind
dickere cake pops stick und die werde
ich jetzt einfach runter und setzen
damit man beim anschneiden die gäste nur
darauf hinweisen dass diese rechnung
drin stecken oder derjenige der die
torte anschneiden nicht einfach beim
anschneiden wegnehmen
[Musik]
beim stapeln mit benutzer auf achten wo
die vorderseite ist vielleicht jetzt
gefordert hier habe ich die vorderseite
und so muss ich jetzt auch richtig drauf
herzlich
[Musik]
und hier drauf kommt jetzt noch das
multicard ist fertig und sie gefällt mir
auch ziemlich verspielt aber dennoch
nicht zu mädchenhaft reise ich finde das
ist von dozent orte also wirklich eine
die mannsgroße mädchen als auch für
jungs machen kann
ich hoffe natürlich dass der oxana und
natürlich auch die trotte gefällt und
dass er natürlich auch gut schmeckt
anschneiden kann ich sie leider nicht
für euch denn ist sehr verschenken und
ich hoffe dass auch er einmal diese
torte nach machen werde ich hoffe ich
konnte euch mit diesem video inspirieren
auch eine motiv auszumachen
und wenn ja dann wünsche ich euch jetzt
schon mal ganz viel spaß dabei und guten
appetit und wir sehen uns nicht zu
machen
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]